>>Female presenter: Hi, everyone. Welcome
to AuthorsGoogle. I'm really excited to introduce
Chris Guillebeau today. Chris is an author,
blogger, and all-around awesome human being.
He wrote the book, The Art of Nonconformity,
and has a really popular blog of the same
name. Chris describes himself as a writer,
traveler, entrepreneur, and general nonconformist,
and he's on a mission to visit every country
in the world before he turns 35. So, he's
currently visited about 151 countries, has
49 to go and is also running his book tour
in similar audacious fashion. He is visiting
all 50 states in a span of about two, two
and a half months as well as ten Canadian
provinces. Chris's goals are to help people
live unconventional lives, make their own
choices, and change the world. I know I've
been personally very inspired by Chris and
his work, so without further ado, Chris Guillebeau.
[applause]
>>Chris: Thanks so much. That was great. Thank
you so much. Thanks, Jenny that was wonderful.
The one thing Jenny didn't mention is that
she's an author herself and her book is coming
out, Life after College, in spring of next
year. So, I'm really excited about that. And
thanks for your help in organizing this. Thanks,
Candice, for the posters, and thanks to all
of you for being here. Thanks for welcoming
me to the Googleplex. So, I am psyched. It
is an unconventional book tour, so because
of that, I don't wanna lecture for an hour.
I'm sure you don't want that, either, and
I'm also going to assume that everyone here
is literate. So, I won't read to you from
the book. If you want to read the book, you
can do so. That's great; if not, that's fine,
too. This is stop number 46 of the Unconventional
Book Tour. It's been so much fun to go all
over the country and talk to fun people about
nonconformity and unconventional life and
work of different forms. So, what I thought
I'd do is I'll talk for about 15, 20 minutes.
I'll tell you a little bit about the book.
I'll tell you why I wrote it and what I hope
will come of it and a couple of things that
are happening with the Art of Nonconformity
in general. And then we'll do what I call
questions and attempted answers for about
15 minutes or so. So, sometimes that goes
better than others, but here, I'm sure, it's
gonna be great; at least we'll have great
questions. And then we'll just hang out and
I'll be in the back after that to sign books
for anybody who wants that. And normally,
I encourage people to bring cupcakes, but
here, at the Googleplex, that doesn't seem
to be an issue. So, again, we'll just hang
out and I'm so glad you're here. Quick audience
survey: How many of you have blogs of your
own?
[pause]
OK. And how many of you use Twitter? Awesome.
OK, about a third with blogs, about 50% Twitter,
nice. So, the first question that often comes
up these days, why bother writing a book?
Like, what's the point? Because we live in
this beautiful, digital age where we can get
information out to people immediately; we
can go tonight and write a blog post about
what happens here today. And no one's gonna
tell us what to say. We have no editors, there's
no gatekeeper. And we can get that message
out to tens of thousands or more people and
if we want instant feedback, we can get that
with Twitter, Facebook, Side Comments, etc.
And I think it's all wonderful, but it also
begs the question, why bother writing a book?
Because a book is almost the opposite of that
process. A book takes forever. The publishing
lifecycle takes a year or more. I wrote this
book last year; it just came out two months
ago. You have to give up control. There's
no guarantee of success, etc. And so I was
thinking about this as I was going through
the writing process and getting ready to publish
the book and I realized that, for me, I was
always a big reader and I grew up reading
books and books were something that were very
special to me, and I could think of probably
five to ten books, at least, that I had read
as a child or a teenager, as an adult, that
had really changed my life, that had really
made a big impact or a big difference. And
after I read the book, I was a different person,
or I made decisions differently. And I couldn't
really think of a lot of blog posts that have
changed my life and I certainly couldn't think
of any tweets that changed my life; just reading
through the tweet deck and like, "Wow. I'm
a different person." Couldn't think of anything
like that. So, I think Twitter is great for
gathering people together and doing this Unconventional
Book Tour and each stop along the way. Twitter,
Facebook, all those things have been fantastic
in bringing people out. And I think it's also
good for making connections and sharing information
and all kinds of things, but I also think
that a lot of digital communication is fleeting
and a lot of it just goes out there and then
we move on to the next thing.
[woman’s voice on intercom interference]
All right. I guess we're gonna keep going.
Great.
[laughter]
So, a lot of communication goes out there
and if you have a blog of your own, you probably
know that your archives are almost never read.
It's mostly only your current posts. Ninety
percent of the traffic is going to your most
recent posts. And so, I guess I still believe
that books, at least, have the potential to
be a little bit longer lasting, to make a
little bit more of an impact, to be something
with a longer timeline, at least a different
format. And it's not for me to say whether
this book will change anyone's life or not;
that's for other people to judge. But I also
think it's good to have a goal and it's good
to define your own success and if you're gonna
undertake a big project, you might as well
decide for yourself what success is gonna
look like. And so, in my case with this book,
my hope with The Art of Nonconformity book
is that people will read it and say not only
it was a good book, but hopefully say, "I
read this book and then I thought differently
about some things and I went and made some
changes, or I made some different decisions."
So, really, the goal is to inspire people
to take action, to create positive change,
or whatever positive change looks like in
their lives. And so, I like to frame the whole
question around something that Gretchen Rubin
said. And Gretchen is the author of The Happiness
Project book and blog and she's been a good
friend and mentor to me, and so on the first
page of the book, Gretchen asks this question
and the question is, "In the face of relentless
pressure to conform, and pressure to avoid
risks, how do we craft the life of our dreams?"
Or another way to put it is, "How do we live
a remarkable life in a conventional world?"
So, that's the central question of the book.
And I use this analogy in the prologue of
jumping off a bridge, or bridge jumping. So,
bridge jumping comes from this experience
you might have had when you were a kid and
you wanted to do something that you probably
shouldn't do and your parent or your teacher
or some authority figure said, "Jenny, why
do you want to do that?" And she said, "Oh,
because Candice is doing it. Because Tim is
doing it." And they said to her, "If everyone
else jumped off a bridge, would you?" So then
she's a little bit disappointed, but she realizes,
hopefully, maybe it's good advice, which is
all fine and well, but then we grow up and
the situation changes; kind of reverses itself.
And we look around and we see that many of
our peers are making the same kind of decisions.
And many of our peers are on one narrow path
and doing the same kind of things in terms
of their education, their career, their relationships,
how they think about money and debt and all
kinds of things. And if we wanna do something
different, if we have an idea maybe to take
the road not taken or even make our own road,
even if it's something that not confrontational,
even if it's not opposed to someone else,
then we often encounter this resistance and
we encounter this pressure to conform, that
Gretchen talked about, or this pressure to
avoid risks. And so, it's almost like everyone's
asking us the opposite question. It's almost
like everyone's saying, "Everyone else is
jumping off the bridge, why aren't you? What's
wrong with you?" And so, the one sentence
statement of why I wrote the book is to bring
the childhood message up to adulthood application
and to say, "You don't have to live your life
the way other people expect you to and you
can do good things for yourself and for others
at the same time." It's not a false choice,
it's not a dichotomy. And here are the stories
of a number of people who have done that in
different ways. So, I wrote the book, there's
a number of stories about me and some people
will relate to those stories and others won't,
and that's OK. But then there's stories of
other people who have somehow overcome the
pressure to conform and pursued an unconventional
choice of their own. So for example, there's
a story of Susan Lewis, who's from Dallas,
Texas, and Susan wanted to make a career change.
She didn't actually want to be an entrepreneur;
she wanted to be part of a company or an organization
bigger than herself, but she realized any
job I apply for, there's probably gonna be
a hundred other people, at least, applying
for this job. And maybe on paper they look
as good as I do, so how can I get around this
situation? How can I circumvent the HR process?
And so, instead of sending out 300 emails
with her resume attached, in hopes that one
company would call her back, Susan created
a website called "Susanhiresaboss.com" and
put her portfolio online and said, "Here's
who I am and here's what I've done, and most
importantly, here's what I would like to do
for the right company or organization. And
I am interviewing prospective bosses. If you'd
like to be considered, fill out this form."
So, of course that's very audacious, especially
at the height of the economic crisis, when
unemployment was 12 to 14% in Texas, but Susan
did this and she got a lot of attention for
it and she got 12 to 14 good job offers from
companies all over North America. And the
company that she ended up going to work for,
or the boss that she hired, to use her language,
was not actually planning on expanding their
organization until he heard about Susan's
project and he was just really impressed with
her initiative and he said, "I have to make
room in my organization for someone like Susan."
There's also a story about a guy named Alan
Bacon and Alan was a self-described conventional
guy with a traditional job and a family, middle-aged,
and Alan was happy with many parts of his
life, but he was also discontented and thinking
about making some change, but he realized,
"I can't make a really big change. I can't
just leave everything behind and move to Thailand,
like some people do. That's great that some
people can do that, but I can't." So what
Alan did instead was, he created what he called
a "series of life experiments." And the life
experiments began with really small things,
things like going to the art museum during
his lunch break. So, every day he drove to
work and he passed this art museum and he
had never been inside. So one day, he went
inside. And then he took up photography, which
was a hobby he had always been interested
in, but had never really pursued. So he bought
a camera, took a class. Then he started doing
some travelling. He started doing some business
travel he hadn't done before. He went overseas
to Europe for the first time and he found
out that he had to go back to France for about
three weeks, and instead of going back by
himself, he found a way to bring his family
with him. So, his wife and their three young
daughters went to France for a three week
cross-cultural immersion experience; talked
about what a good decision that was for the
family. And then Alan started consulting and
now he's completely self-employed. And he
traces the whole process to the early idea
of the life experiments; to just being willing
to experiment with change, to see change as
something welcoming instead of something fearful.
So, the story of Susan, the story of Alan,
a number of other people in the book, again,
with the goal of inspiring readers to take
action, to create positive change, to take
action to maybe step back from the bridge
and take a different look and see, "How can
I pursue my own unconventional life?" And
so, when we talk about things like change,
and we talk about nonconformity, unconventional
living, all these kinds of things, it’s
good to mention that these are not things
that everyone cares about, and not everyone's
interested in change and not everyone wants
to live unconventionally, and that's OK. So,
I get a lot of emails and from time to time,
people will write in and say, "I have a very
traditional life, what do you have against
me?" And it gives me a great opportunity to
say I have nothing against you and I wish
you well and that's great, I'm so glad you're
happy. The problem is that a lot of other
people are not happy with that and maybe not
so much unhappy, but I would say a lot of
people are discontented and a lot of people
are dissatisfied with the idea of doing things
the way they've always been done. And so,
in many ways, the fundamental message of The
Art of Nonconformity, the whole project, is
really for the discontented. It's a self-selecting
group of people who do want to do something
different. And for those of us who find ourselves
in that group, for people who identify with
that and say, "Yes, I do want to pursue the
road not taken, or make my own road," I've
been doing these meet-ups all across the country.
San Francisco is number 46 and out of all
these conversations, I've developed just two
suggestions. So, two suggestions for those
of us who find ourselves in that group. The
first suggestion is that these days, there
is a lot of conversation about efficiency,
about how to be the most efficient person
or the most productive, or how to live the
most optimal life; how to get up at 5 o'clock
in the morning and read your 60 RSS feeds
by 6 AM, or how to outsource your life and
get other people to do things for you, so
that you can detach yourself from humanity.
And I think that's a little bit overrated.
And my response to that would be the same
as with the other people. I would say, "If
that works for you; that's great, if that
rocks your world, wonderful." But for those
of us who might be a little bit uncomfortable
with that, or for those of us who might wonder,
"Is that it? Is that the answer?" I would
say that there's an alternative, and the alternative
to pursuing efficiency for efficiency's sake,
is to pursue meaningful adventure. So, things
like, in my case, visiting every country in
the world. For those of you who read the blog,
you know it's a highly inefficient quest.
I spend a lot of time and money and energy
sorting out plane tickets and logistics and
Visas and sleeping on the floor of the airport
all over the world, and getting kicked out
of various countries. And it's all very inefficient
and in many ways, my life could be much easier
if I just didn't do that; if I just lived
at home in Portland, Oregon, maybe travelled
around the States, maybe traveled once a year.
But I don't do it because it’s efficient
or productive; I do it because it’s meaningful.
It brings personal joy to me; that's why I
do it. Another example would be this book
tour itself. About 90 days before the book
came out, I talked to my publisher and I said,
"Hey guys. What's the plan for the book tour?
Where am I going?" And they said, "Oh, we
don't have any money for that and we don't
really believe in book tours anymore. Most
authors don't really want to do them anyway."
And they said, "You can come to New York if
you want." And I said, "Well, New York is
great, but not everyone lives there." So,
I just decided if there's no official book
tour, well that's OK. I'll make my own. And
I don't want to do anything small, so I don't
want to only do major markets. So, that's
how the whole 50 state thing came about and
I didn't want to leave out Canada, so all
the provinces up there. And I just figured
it’s not only me, it's all of my great readers.
I have great readers all over the country
and we'll just make this happen and we'll
find a way to do it, however we can do it.
And it's been so fantastic. It's been so much
fun, so rewarding, so meaningful and it's
great that I can go to places and have great
crowds. It's great that I can come here to
Google, but some of the smaller stops, in
many ways, have actually been more meaningful;
to go to a place like North Dakota where there's
nine people, until a few days before. I went
to West Virginia and there was only one person
on the sign-up list and her name was Nancy.
So I wrote to her and said, "Nancy, you have
to be there. You can't get sick, you can't
skip it, because it's you and me and West
Virginia."
[laughter]
So it's one of those things that doesn't make
sense from an economic perspective, or from
a marketing perspective. But again, it's an
adventure. It's fun. So, instead of efficiency,
consider meaningful adventure. And the second
of just two suggestions comes from the awareness
that these are really privileged conversations
that we're able to have. And I think it's
fantastic that we can talk about things like
what kind of work we would like to do and
how we would like to spend our time and what
blogs we read. And so, it's great, but it's
also very unusual; it's very remarkable and
it's very privileged to be able to talk about
these things. And so, something that I think
is missing from the whole conversation about
alternative life and work, is this question
of contribution; the question, "What can we
contribute?" instead of just, "What can we
consume?" or "How can we engage instead of
detach?" And so, that's why I say that the
two most important questions in the universe
are, number one, what do you really want to
get out of life? Because a lot of people don't
know what they want, so I think if they can
figure that out, that's great. But then, number
two, what can you offer the world that no
one else can? So that's that question of contribution,
a question of engagement. And it's good to
say, when we talked about contribution, and
it's not entirely a selfless act, it's not
a sacrificial thing, at least not entirely,
because we ourselves benefit as we contribute,
and we, ourselves, are made better as we seek
to answer that question of contribution. So,
it's good for everyone. And my story is, after
9/11, I was depressed like everyone else and
just asking myself the big questions of life
and my wife and I are talking about what can
we do and is there a way we can respond? How
can we do something to give back? And it was
out of that situation that we ended up moving
to West Africa and living in Sierra Leone
and Liberia for about four years, volunteering
for a medical charity. And it was just the
most amazing, transformative experience of
our lives. It was very good for us and we
would come back to the States about every
year or so, and we would talk with people
about what we were doing, and people would
say things like, "Oh, that's amazing. How
sacrificial of you." And we realized pretty
quickly to become uncomfortable with that
kind of dialogue because we would say, Oh,
it is great that we can do this and it is
wonderful that we can be a part of something
bigger than ourselves and that we can help
an organization that's working in post-conflict
countries, and that's good. And people's lives
are being made better through that, but it's
not the whole story. The whole story is that
our lives are being made better through this,
also. And we are also being changed. So really
this is the best decision that we've ever
made. And so, that's why I call it a selfish
generosity as we seek to answer that question
of contribution and we, ourselves, are made
better. So, when you put all these things
together, along with this opportunity to embrace
life as a meaningful adventure, instead of
something to be lived to its most efficient
state all the time, along with the imperative
to really think about contribution and think
about what we can give and how we can engage.
I think what it all comes down to is a question
of legacy, of what will our legacy be? And
what are we building and what kind of story
do we hope to tell with our lives and what
will the ultimate impact of our lives be?
And I think of legacy as having nothing to
do with money, nothing to do with inheritance,
even career. It's certainly nothing that we
think about at the end of our lives, looking
back, when we can't really make any changes,
but rather, legacy is something to think about
from whatever stage in our life we're in.
And I think it's a question of influence and
relationships and that part of contribution
that I talked about. And so, that's what I've
been trying to do with The Art of Nonconformity,
with the blog, and now the book, the business,
the whole community. I like to be very clear
that it's been a work in progress from the
beginning and it continues to be. I wasn't
really clear about the project in the beginning
and that's normally how it goes. I began with
a classic blogging strategy of making shit
up. I'm sure no one at Google is familiar
with that, but that's how I started and fortunately,
a number of people came along and engaged,
and contributed, and participated and asked
good questions and made the project so much
better than it would've been just with me.
And so, I'm extremely grateful for that and
I consider myself extremely fortunate to have
responsibility for this community. And just
to let you know, two very quick things for
those of you who are interested, the first
thing is that this book is actually a partnership
with my friends at Charity Water and we're
working with two communities in Ethiopia to
bring clean water and sanitation. And so,
if you get the book in any form, print or
digital, if you just write your name down
on this notebook today and then all the money
that I get for the book will go to the project
in Ethiopia. And the second thing is as I've
been doing these meet-ups all over the country,
I realized that the best thing about the whole
event, the whole space, is not this formal
time where I'm talking, but really all the
other people who come out in the before and
the after space. So I was trying to think
how can we scale this experience? How can
we do this? How can we bring remarkable people
together, not just from one city, but all
over the world? And so, I created the World
Domination Summit, which I'm hosting next
June in Portland, Oregon, and I rented out
the Portland Art Museum and I'm working with
a great team to bring together speakers and
workshop leaders. It's gonna be very participatory
and so if you're interested in that, I have
an invitation for you. But mostly, I always
want to say that I get paid in nice emails
and in blog trackbacks and so I'm so grateful
for everyone who's been a part of the project
and if you're new, that's great, too. Whenever
I see people writing about The Art of Nonconformity,
I just have the same feeling that I would
have of getting paid. So, I'm very grateful
for that. And the last thing I wanna say before
we can do the Questions and Attempted Answers
and then we'll hang out, is I always like
to talk to people about their own projects,
about their own blogs and businesses and adventures
and things, and on this tour so far, I've
been hearing from a lot of people thinking
about starting something. And the question
of a topic varies quite a bit in terms of
what they're thinking about starting and what
they're thinking about doing, but I have noticed
this common theme, and the common theme is
"I worry I'm too late." "I worry I'm too late
to do this." So, if it’s a business idea,
I worry that the marketplace has passed me
by. If it's something else, maybe I just worry
that I'm too late in life. I should've done
this years ago or whatever. And I think it's
really interesting because I always say it's
good to do market research, it's good to think
about your motivations and understand what
you really want to do and if you're gonna
stick with it. And all those things are great,
but I also realize that that's exactly how
I felt three years ago when I started The
Art of Nonconformity. And I looked around
and lots of other successful bloggers and
authors and I thought, "Do I really have a
unique message to share? And I should've started
this a long time ago." And so, there's all
this fear and insecurity and anxiety and somehow
I managed to overcome that and I'm so glad
I did because now here we are together and
now there's this book tour and now the project
is so much bigger than what it was. And I'm
very grateful for that. And so, I always say
when someone asks, "what is the best time
to start?" I always say the best time to start
was last year, but failing that, today will
do. So, I'm happy to share whatever it is
I've learned about unconventional life, work,
and travel along the way, and I know I'm among
a great community of people who know all about
starting things, but mostly I would encourage
you as well to find a way to share your story
with those who can benefit from it. And thanks
so much for having me here, on stop number
46 of The Unconventional Book Tour.
[applause]
So, questions and attempted answers with the
microphone.
[pause]
>>Male audience #1: Hi Chris. My name is James.
Thanks for coming here and doing this talk.
So, I think I looked a little bit at your
blog yesterday and you talk about travelling
long-term and also making money on the side.
And on one hand, I also saw something about
AdWords and AdSense Arbitrage. Can you tell
us a little bit more about that?
>>Chris: Sure. Well, I can probably explain
how I got started as an entrepreneur and then
the transition to the blog. So, thanks James,
for a great question. I got started as an
entrepreneur about ten years ago. I just discovered
that I wasn't a good employee. I was unemployable,
basically. It's a long story. I go into it
in the book, but my motivation in the beginning
was how can I find a way to support myself?
I don't necessarily need to get rich, but
how can I find a way to support myself without
working for someone else? So, I would say
it's a low-level motivation. But, I started
a coffee importing business; I started selling
things on eBay way back in the day when eBay
was new. Then, I was a designer for a while
and then I realized that I was a good designer
in 1999. And things had changed a little bit,
so now I work with a great designer partner.
But I did a number of things with Google AdWords,
also in the early days. I did affiliate marketing
and I created information products and all
of that. So, I had a kind of scattered history
as an entrepreneur; I never built a big company
or anything. It was mostly, like, my motivation,
again, was to support myself and my wife and
I went overseas for four years and I was able
to do that without taking a salary from the
organization. So, that was great. But then,
I moved back to the States in 2006 and I realized
I had done a number of things that were somewhat
interesting to some people, but they were
all kind of unrelated. So I wanted to create
convergence. I felt like I had been an entrepreneur,
I'd been an aid worker, I have this travel
thing I was starting to do where I was trying
to visit every country, but I had no platform.
And so, that was where The Art of Nonconformity
came from. And in terms of the monetization
with the site, that was also a very organic
thing. I get a lot of credit for being strategic
and it's totally false. Really, in the beginning,
I had no monetization plan at all and what
I found was as the project grew, I kept getting
a lot of the same questions, a lot of technical
question about how I do my travel without
round the world plane tickets and frequent
flyer miles and travel hacking, and then also
about microbusinesses and entrepreneurship
on a very small scale. And so, I just decided
to create additional resources for sale for
those who wanted that. And I try to be very
clear in the beginning and still am that I
do most of my work for free. Eighty percent,
90% of the work is for free and then the 10%
or 20% is there for people who want it. So,
I built that store up along the way. And now,
UnconventionalGuides.com, which is the related
side business to Art of Nonconformity, is
really how I make a living and how I support
myself. Basically, what I've tried to do is
listen to my community and I've tried to understand
what they want and what resources they're
looking for, what needs that they have and
try to then find a way to meet those needs.
And that's how the monetization has come about.
[pause]
There's a long line here at the question,
but just try to make your way through.
[pause]
>>Male audience #2: Hi, Chris. I feel that
most of the time the best catalyst for action
is inspiration. And I feel as if inspiration
is something you get from role models. But
growing up, I feel I've been let down by most
of my role models, especially public figures,
so in order to nonconform, what are your thoughts
on where I can find role models to inspire
me?
>>Chris: What kind of role model are you looking
for?
>>audience #2: It's a purposely vague question.
>>Chris: OK.
>>audience #2: I feel as if I wanted to do
something big, I would need a feeling, a wanting
to be like someone.
>>Chris: OK.
>>audience #2: And so, in one sense, perhaps
the leaders of this company are my role models
for how I would lead the company.
>>Chris: Sure. That's great. What's your name?
>>audience #2: Mattheas.
>>Chris: Mattheas. OK, thanks. That's a good
question. I'm just thinking about how to answer
it that's not purposely vague. I think I also
take inspiration from people and I don't know
if I would say they're role models. I mean
maybe they are. I would just say I like hearing
the stories of other people who've done different
things, or who have overcome something, or
have pursued a big project, a big dream. And
hopefully, found a way to connect that dream
with the lives of other people. So, I guess
even if I was to feel let down by someone,
hopefully there's still something in their
life that I can look up to and derive inspiration
from. And part of the project, something I've
tried to be very careful about, is to maintain
what I call an anti-guru philosophy. So, I
try very hard. Sometimes people ask me specific
questions about their own lives and their
careers and what they're trying to do, and
if I can be helpful in that, I will, but I
don't have any claim that I can provide the
answer. So, I always try to reflect back on
people. So, I still take a lot of inspiration
from the people who read the site and the
stories that they send me. And I take inspiration
from other bloggers, other authors, and not
just people who are public figures, but people
who are doing fun things. So, I guess I'm
not looking for one role model or one big
person who I say I want to emulate that person,
but I try to take something from a variety
of people. And then you look at that person’s
life and you say, "What do I like about this?
And how can I adapt this, or apply this characteristic
to me?" And then, obviously, not everything
about them will relate to you, so maybe you
take something from someone and something
from someone else. And then, hopefully, at
some point, that's where your identity comes
from.
[pause]
>>Female audience #1: Hi, I'm Sheba. So my
question is that the older I get and the more
stuff I have accumulated, and the more relationships
I have, like my husband, my kids, it's harder
and harder to do unconventional things. I
mean, mostly like travel and things like that.
Those, in my head, I would love to do that,
but I don't get to do a lot of those things.
So what advice would you have for someone
in my situation?
>>Chris: OK, great. So, one of the things
that's really helped in the beginning, as
I said, like people came along and asked good
questions. I started by writing about my own
trips and then people would say things like,
"Well, I don't want to travel," or, "I'm not
able to travel right now. Isn't nonconformity
bigger than that?" Of course, the answer is
yes. So I had to back up a little bit. What
I've tried to do recently is to look at people
in different situations and to look at families,
for example. This comes up a lot. And some
families do want to travel and have some kind
of international adventure and some don't,
and either way is fine. For those who do want
that, then there are examples of people who've
done that. And a number of people have been
able to have a big adventure. There's a story
in the book of a family who goes by the name
Soul Travelers 3, so they are soultravellors3.com
or soultravelers3 on Twitter. And they've
been raising their five-year old daughter,
who I think is now eight or nine, and they've
been living in a number of different countries
and they make about 24,000 dollars a year.
And they have a blog where they talk about
how they do that and the choices that they've
made and the priorities that they've chosen
above other priorities to make happen. But
then the other thing is whether you want to
travel or not, I think these are good conversations
to have as a family. And it's good to talk,
as a family, or a couple, or whatever your
situation is, and say, "OK, what are your
dreams? What are my dreams? And it's OK for
us if some of those dreams are different.
That's OK, but maybe there's also a shared
experience that we can create, something we
want to do as a family." And then, I like
to reverse engineer things and say, "OK, this
is my goal, this would be fun. How can we
make this happen? How do we step back from
that and figure out everything that needs
to happen for that to take place." So, I was
talking with Jenny today about her upcoming
book launch and all of her plans for that.
And I'm sure she'll share about that at some
point. But we were talking about what she
wanted to make happen and what needed to take
place to make that come about. So, I think
it’s good to have conversations. I think
it’s good to have joint planning sessions.
It’s good to find a way to support each
other’s dreams. What's up?
>>Male audience #3: Hi, Chris. I'm Ryan.
>>Chris: Hi Ryan.
>>audience #3: Speaking of families, I was
curious what your upbringing was like that
pushed you into this obsession with nonconformity?
>>Chris: About my upbringing. Well, I had
a split family, like a lot of people do. And
so, I had basically two sets of families I
was growing up with and my mom was married
to a guy in the Air Force, so we moved around
a lot. I lived in the Philippines for a couple
of years as a child, which I didn't enjoy
so much as a kid. I was like, six to nine
growing up and I was separated from my dad,
who was back in the States. So I didn't enjoy
that so much then, but I think in the long-term
it was good; a good, cross-cultural experience.
And then, I wasn't a very good student. I'm
actually a high school dropout. I talk about
that in the book. I went to one year of high
school and then just left and I ended up going
to college after that. So, I guess in some
ways I had privileges and other ways, I was
kind of a rebel, or anti-authoritarian in
some ways.
>>audience #3: Cool. Thanks.
>>Chris: Thanks, man.
>>Male audience #4: Let me start with this
one. What sort of mental techniques do you
use to try to quelch risk-aversion? So, if
you're going on a trip around the world and
you've got this stuff in your backpack and
this amount of money in the bank, there's
certainly scenarios that you could get yourself
in trouble. So, you or other people that you've
read, what sort of techniques do you use to
say, "I'm really ready to do this, I'm as
safe as I can be. Let's just go for it."
>>Chris: That's a great question. What was
your name?
>>audience #4: Jeremy.
>>Chris: Jeremy thanks. That was awesome.
I don't know if I have any mental techniques,
but I guess what I try to do and what I encourage
people to do is think about risk differently,
and maybe redefine risk a little bit. So,
the example of travel; this comes up a lot.
People always ask me about dangerous countries
and bad things that have happened and aren't
you scared, etc. And I always point out that
there are some dangerous countries in the
world, yes. But the list is very, very small.
Basically, like five to ten countries in the
world that actually could be called dangerous
and there's 180 countries which are totally
fine. So, I also say the more you do something,
then the more comfortable you become. When
the risk comes about, or the feeling of risk,
the fear, usually comes about when we haven't
done something and we're thinking about doing
something, but we don't know what it’s like.
Once we get the experience, we look back and
say, "Oh, maybe not so much." The other thing
I would say about risk is, in terms of entrepreneurships,
small business, working for companies; traditionally
security has been defined as working for a
company. And entrepreneurship is seen as the
risky alternative and entrepreneurs take risks.
Therefore, they are rewarded for their risk,
or they might fail. And I think a lot of what's
happened over the past few years has redefined
that. And I think a lot of beliefs have been
questioned. We used to have the belief that
the stock market is always going to go up.
We used to have the belief that homeownership
is the best choice for everyone. And, I think,
more and more people are looking at that and
saying, "What is risk? And what is security?"
In my case, I think it would be risky for
me to have a job. I think working for myself
is the less risky, I think it’s the safe,
conservative choice. So, people often talk
about risk in the sense of starting a business,
but it can actually be a very safe choice.
So, I like to think about risk and think about
what the real risk is and maybe redefine it.
>>Male audience #5: Hi, Chris. My name is
Dan. I'm interested because a lot of bloggers
that I read, who have this sort of message
like do your own thing, like live your own
life, tend to make money from their blogs
or an associated online business. And, obviously,
you're doing some of that.
>>Chris: Sure.
>>audience #5: But you've done some other
things. Like, you mentioned the coffee importing
business and designing and stuff. So I'm not
gonna ask what job should you do if you're
interested in this, but I'm interested in
what kind of feeling you get when you do these
sort of jobs and what is it that makes you
think, like what's the kind of feeling you
get when you're like, "Oh, i should keep doing
this. This is going well," versus, "I should
drop this and try something different."
>>Chris: OK, good, so a couple different questions
there. I would say in terms of the feeling
I get, and maybe you're asking what motivates
me, or what--
>>audience #6: Yeah, yeah.
>>Chris: Where do I find encouragement? I
would say the encouragement is mostly through
the daily engagement with what I call the
small army of remarkable people. You know,
so the people who are a part of the community,
both online and offline. So, every day I get
a lot of emails, just like all of you do.
And many of the emails are people talking
about sharing their own story and sharing
what they’re doing that's unconventional,
different, and how they're overcoming pressure
and how our lives are connected. And I find
that very motivating. I find that very encouraging
and as I said earlier, inspiring to me. Now
as to what other should do, I mean, that's
a big, broad question. I guess I always think
a couple of things. One, I think it’s very
difficult to do something on a long term basis
that you're not motivated to do. I think it’s
much easier to do what you're motivated to
do as opposed to trying to motivate yourself
into something. We all have things we have
to do, like suck it up, get it done, but I
think if that's your career, then that's very
difficult. So as much as possible, again,
for those of us in a relatively privileged
setting, as much as possible, I think it’s
good to forge your life and your career around
things that you're motivated to do and things
you're excited about. And in terms of blogging,
whether you want to have a commercially successful
bog or just a blog that's popular or just
a blog that a few people read, the question
to answer is always, "Why should other people
care about this, and what's in it for them?"
And what are their needs and how are you providing
a solution their needs? And if you do that,
then people will be interested in it. If not,
probably not so much. And did you wanna have
a follow-up?
>>audience #5: I just, you know, sorry. I
guess it's kind of a vague question, but I'm
most interested in the motivation thing. Like,
when you start something new, is there a lot
of well, I gotta push through and do this
grunt work and that grunt work until I get
there? Or do you find that when you find a
groove, you really hit it and you're motivated
from the start?
>>Chris: For the most part, I enjoy almost
everything I do. For the most part, I enjoy
the process of creating; I enjoy the process
of responding. I guess, again with the motivation,
what I'm interested in at this point is influence
and how can we grow the community in a scalable
way, that makes sense and is appropriate,
not too fast, not too slow. But for the most
part, I love what I do. I mean, I have a great
life. I'm very grateful. Thanks.
>>Female audience #2: I'm Jen. I was wondering
if you have any advice on how to know when
to let a project go and how to do so without
feeling guilty? I've been writing a blog for
a few years and I have a few hundred followers.
I don't want to let them down, but I'm not
gathering as much fulfillment from writing
the blog anymore. But I continue to do it
out of not letting them down.
>>Chris: You do it out of obligation?
>>audience #2: Yeah.
>>Chris: OK. Well, have you considered maybe
having a dialogue with those readers or followers
and maybe just expressing your feelings? I
mean, this is something that's actually, blog
readers respond very well to expressions of
your personal motivation and what you're feeling
in terms of fulfillment. So, it’s almost
a kind of thing where if I felt that situation,
I would try to think a bit myself and think,
"OK, why am I feeling this way? I was excited
about this before, but something changed.
What changed? Is there a way that we can recreate
what I had before, or is it just time to move
on and do something else?" And if that's the
case, then that's fine. But it may also be
helpful to, instead of just focusing inwardly,
one question that people always ask when you're
trying to figure out what to do, a lot of
life coaches encourage people to ask themselves
the question, "What excites you?" So I think
that's good. I think it's good, but I think
it's only a good start. So, I think you think
about what excites you, but also what bothers
you. What bothers you about the world and
so, that's a little bit more of an external
focus. So, in this case, maybe having a dialogue
with the readers of the community, and just
sharing what you just shared and saying, “I
was really excited about this for a while,
but now some things have changed in my life,
or maybe I'm motivated by different things.
What do you think about that? And I think
I might change the project entirely, or I
might start a new one, but let's have a conversation
about it."
>>Male audience #6: Hi, Chris. I'm wondering
what advice would you give for gaining the
understanding of families in our pursuits
of nonconformity, or just motivation and happiness.
I'm speaking particularly to living in a different
place, travelling abroad, what is a good balance
and how do we achieve it between being happy
with our lives and getting other people to
understand that we're happy with our lives?
>>Chris: Right. That's a very good question.
And maybe we should actually end with this
question and them I'm gonna hang out in the
back for anybody who wants to talk or sign
a book. There's a number of things we could
say about that. I guess when we talk about
resistance and pressure to conform it often
comes from family or close friends who don't
understand why we want to do something. And
I think often, what is the case, especially
in terms of travel or living somewhere else,
like you mentioned, I think there's a fear
that you're gonna leave and never come back.
And so, sometimes it’s an irrational fear,
or it’s a fear that something is going to
be different or changed. And so, sometimes
it helps just to do something, or to go on
a trip or whatever and then you come back
and the people say, "Oh, OK. He went away
and then he came back and he's still the person,
the son, the brother, the husband, the partner,
or whoever, that I knew before." And so, I
would say in many cases, people just get used
to things over time. If you spend your life
trying to persuade them, trying to persuade
people to go along, you may be successful,
but you could spend years doing that. Or,
you could just step out a little bit and then
hopefully people will adjust. And often, that
fear comes out of, that resistance, comes
out of fear and envy or jealousy. Or maybe
people wanna do something themselves, but
they haven't been able to or they don't see
how they can do it. So, what's fun is by doing
that, by actually stepping out and pursuing
whatever the unconventional choice is. In
your case, what's fun is that you can then
be an inspiration to them. And they're not
going to read books about nonconformity. They
don't read blogs, but they know you and your
part of their lives. So, if you've done that,
then you're an inspiration and hopefully maybe
they'll take a step as well. I could say a
lot more about that, but I think our time
is up here, unless there's one more question.
Jenny, did you wanna say anything else? That's
good. You guys are awesome. Thank you so much
for having me. I'm gonna be at Rocket Room
in San Francisco tonight at 7 pm. Thank you.
[applause]